NATASHA, WE ARE LEARNING THAT
THE CIA DIRECTOR WENT TO KYIV
FOR THIS MEETING THAT NO ONE
KNEW ABOUT WITH PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY AND A LOT OF THAT WAS
TO TALK ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
OFFENSIVES THIS SPRING.
>> Reporter: YEAH, JOHN, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THE U.S. IS VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT AND IS WATCHING
VERY CLOSELY, NOT LEAST BECAUSE
THE UKRAINIANS AS CLARISSA SAID,
HAVE BEEN SOUNDING THE ALARM ON
A POTENTIAL MAJOR RUSSIAN
OFFENSIVE IN THE WORKS BECAUSE
NOT ALL OF ITS TROOPS THAT HAVE
BEEN MOBILIZED HAVE ACTUALLY
GOING TO UKRAINE YET, SO THEY
STILL HAVE PEOPLE IN RESERVE WHO
WOULD BE ABLE TO POTENTIALLY
LAUNCH A NEW OFFENSIVE AGAINST
UKRAINE.
WHAT WE ARE LEARNING IS THAT THE
CIA DIRECTOR BILL BURNS WHO
REALLY HAS EMERGED AS KIND OF A
KEY EMISSARY BETWEEN THE U.S.,
UKRAINE AND EVEN RUSSIA, WENT TO
UKRAINE TO BRIEF PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY ON THE U.S. ASSESSMENT
OF WHERE RUSSIA MIGHT STRIKE
NEXT.
NOW, RUSSIA OF COURSE THEY HAVE
BEEN KIND OF ON THE DEFENSIVE IN
CERTAIN AREAS OF UKRAINE,
INCLUDING IN THE DONBAS, WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF COURSE OF
BAKHMUT WHERE A LOT OF HEAVY
FIGHTING HAS BEEN HAPPENING, BUT
WHAT THE U.S. SEEMS TO BELIEVE
NOW IS THAT RUSSIA IS, IN FACT,
PREPARING FOR A POTENTIAL MAJOR
OFFENSIVE AND THEY WANT
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY OF COURSE TO
BE READY FOR THAT AND TO HAVE
ALL OF THE INFORMATION THAT HE
NEEDS, INCLUDING OF COURSE KEY
INTELLIGENCE TO BE ABLE TO
POSITION TROOPS AND BE ABLE TO
FIGHT THAT BACK.
NOW, IT REMAINS TO BE SEEN
WHETHER OR NOT RUSSIA IS GOING
TO BE DOING ANOTHER MAJOR
MOBILIZATION, THAT IS SOMETHING
THE UKRAINIANS HAVE ALSO BEEN
WARNING ABOUT.
RIGHT NOW THE U.S. SEEMS TO BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE RELUCTANT ABOUT
WHETHER THAT CAN ACTUALLY HAPPEN
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE HERE IS THAT
THE U.S. AND UKRAINIANS ARE
SOUNDING THE ALARM ABOUT A
POTENTIAL MAJOR RUSSIAN ATTACK
HERE.
>> AND WHAT'S SO SIGNIFICANT
ABOUT THAT WAS THAT IT WAS JUST
ABOUT A YEAR AGO THAT THE CIA
DIRECTOR BURNS ALSO HAD INFORMED
UKRAINIANS OF U.S. INTELLIGENCE
SHOWING THAT RUSSIA WOULD, IN
FACT, INVADE.
UKRAINE AT THE TIME SAID THAT
THEIR INTELLIGENCE DIDN'T MATCH
THAT.
CLEARLY THEY ARE TAKING WHAT
THEY HEAR FROM BURNS THIS TIME
AROUND VERY SERIOUSLY.
U.S. THIS DEFENSE SECRETARY AND
GERMANY RIGHT NOW, AND UKRAINE
SAYS THE GATHERING COULD DECIDE
THE FATE OF THE WAR.
DOZENS OF DEFENSE LEADERS FROM
AROUND THE WORLD ARE DISCUSSING
WHETHER TO PROVIDE KYIV WITH
HEAVY WEAPONS, GERMANY IS UNDER
MOUNTING PRESSURE TO SEND THIS
LETTER TO TANK TO THE UKRAINIAN
BATTLEFIELD, OR AT LEAST ALLOW
THEM TO BE TRANSFERRED FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES THAT HAVE THEM.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY MADE IT A
PASSIONATE PLEA VIA VIDEOLINK
URGING WESTERN ALLIES TO SEND
THEIR WEAPONS WITHOUT DELAY.
>> THE WAR STARTED BY RUSSIA,
THAT HAS NOT ALLOWED --
AND I CAN'T THANK YOU, HUNDREDS
OF TIMES, IT WILL BE ABSOLUTELY
JUST GREAT.
ALL THAT YOU HAVE DONE, BUT
HUNDREDS OF THANK YOU, HUNDREDS
OF TANKS.
>> NOW A HUGE AMOUNT OF
PRESSURE ON GERMANY BECAUSE
UKRAINE NEEDS TANKS, BUT AT THE
SAME TIME, THE U.S. CAN GIVE
THEM TANKS, BUT DOES NOT, WHY
IS THAT?
>> THE U.S. LAID OUT AN
EXPENSIVE DEAL, TWO POINT $5
MILLION WORTH THEY SAY, THEY
CHOSE NOT TO SUPPLY WHAT --
BECAUSE THEY SIMPLY WOULD NOT
SUIT SITUATIONS ON THE GROUND
FOR YOU CREAM, IT IS TOO
COMPLICATED TO RUN, TOO
COMPLICATED TO MAINTAIN, AND
THE LOGISTICAL CHALLENGES ARE
ALSO COMPLEX.
THEY ARE NOT SAYING THAT THEY
ARE NOT IN FAVOR OF TANK
SUPPORT FROM THE EUROPEAN
PARTNERS.
IN FACT, THE U.S. IS IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THAT, AND WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE NATO AND
EUROPEAN ALLIES, URGING GERMANY
IN PARTICULAR TO SUPPORT
UKRAINE THROUGH THE SUPPLY OF
THE TANKS.
>> THEY MAKE THEM, AND THE DEAL
IS, WHEN THEY SELL INTO ANOTHER
COUNTRY, THEY CAN'T BE PASSED
ON ABOUT GERMANY'S POSITION.
ALL THE TANKS ACROSS EUROPE,
WHICH GERMANY EFFECTIVELY HAS
THE KEY TO.
>> GERMANY HOLDS THE EXPORT
LICENSE, NOT THEY ARE KEEN TO
HIGHLIGHT, THEY SAY THEY ARE
READY AND PREPARED TO SUPPLY
THE TANKS FROM POLAND TO
UKRAINE, THEY ARE WORKING ON
THE GREEN LIGHT FROM GERMANY,
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE SO MUCH
INTERNATIONAL PRESSURE ON THE
GERMAN GOVERNMENT TO DO SO.
WE HAVE HEARD THAT GERMANY SAT
SIDE BY SIDE IN SUPPORT WITH
THE INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS FOR
UKRAINE.
AT THIS STAGE, THEY HAVE NOT
ALLOWED WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WILL BE OFFERING THOSE TANKS AS
SUPPORT.
OF COURSE, THERE IS QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE
STILL WAITING FOR PERHAPS THE
U.S. TO OFFER FIRM OFFER OF
TANKS, THIS IS A MIGHT GO AHEAD
WITH THAT IF THERE WAS A
SIMILAR OFFER FROM THE U.S..
THAT HAS NOT HAPPENED, OF
COURSE, THIS MEETING TODAY IS
FOCUSED ON THE SUPPLY OF TANKS.
WE'VE HEARD FROM UKRAINE'S
DEFENSE MINISTER OLEKSII ROSS
MCAULIFFE, HE IS PRESENT AT THE
MEETING, HE OUTLINED THE THREE
KEY THINGS THAT UKRAINE WANTS
TO ACHIEVE ON TWITTER.
HE SAYS MORE AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEMS.
THEY WERE SECURING ALL MY
SUPPLIES AS WELL AS WHERE AS
REPAIR SERVICING REPORTS, THE
THIRD THING THEY NEED IS TANKS,
MORE MODERN TANKS.
>> THIS IS BASED ON, ROUGHLY,
THE FEELING THAT THERE WILL BE
A SPRING OFFENSIVE?
AND THEY WILL BE ON THE GROUND?
AND THEY WILL NEED IT TANKS TO
FEND THEMSELVES?
AND TO PUSH FORWARD ON THE
RUSSIAN LINE.
>> WE HEARD FROM THE
INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS OF THE
U.S., THEY ARE READY TO STAND
BY UKRAINE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
DEFENSE OF SUPPORT.
THE QUESTION IS HOW FAR ARE
THEY PREPARED TO GO TO SUPPORT
UKRAINE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
OFFENSIVE SUPPORT THAT THEY
DESPERATELY WANT?
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH INDEED.